how to start a photography business in
three simple steps I got a question from
one of my youtube viewers love you guys
the buy-in there by n how I hope you
pronounce it wrote in hello Evan I need
your help I have a computer and I have
good skills in photography now I want to
get into the business of photography
what should i do how should I go about
starting so this is a great question
because photography it's one of the most
competitive businesses you can get into
because everybody thinks their
photographer so you're going up against
professional photographers as well as a
lot of amateurs who do it for free you
know families relative members so it's
it's hard to get this business going
here's how to do it in three steps okay
number one have an edge you have to have
something that's different about your
photography business because there are
so many photographers what makes you
different what makes you stand out and
it's not just targeting weddings because
tons of photographers target weddings -
what is different and you want to think
about the kind of style that you bring
because some people will love your style
and some people will hate it so describe
it so that people can help self identify
themselves
here's an example a buddy of mine named
rich runs a company called you gotta
love that you gotta love calm and his
style he called it heightened reality so
all of his stuff is over the edge wild
over the top and he works with
celebrities like Lady Gaga and Kardinal
Offishall these are the people who ends
up hiring him because they love his over
the edge crazy style and so he attracts
people who are over the edge and crazy
through his heightened reality branding
messaging website what is it that's
different about you because if you just
say wedding photographer you're not
going to stand out so think about how
you take pictures your process the style
you like the feeling you want to get
across and make that evident and
everything that you you talk about on
your website and your marketing so that
when someone who feels the same way
sees your stuff and here's what you're
saying they say I have to have that guy
he's my photographer because he
is XYZ okay step number one number two I
would honestly start by going to work
for somebody else and you might be
thinking what Evan is the entrepreneur
guy you believe in entrepreneurs you let
me go get a job the reason why you get a
job is to learn and if you can go work
for a photographer that you look up to
and respect you'll learn so much more
than just trying to do things yourself
and that may mean working for them for
three months or six months I'm not
talking about taking a 10 year career
with them just enough so that you learn
how the business is done you'll learn
how to get clients you'll learn how they
take shoots you'll become a better
photographer in the process and editing
the pictures as well everything you'll
get better at and you'll get paid to
learn about this business and when you
go and you start yourself you will have
a much higher degree chance of success
because you've made your mistakes on
somebody else's dime and number three is
go get partnerships the fastest way to
grow business is to partner up with
somebody who's already selling to your
target audience
so think about who is selling to your
target customers and find a way to
partner up with them people who are
selling non photography related products
and services if you sell into the
wedding industry you can think about
who's the caterer who are they buying
the the getting the limo from where they
renting the tuxedos from where they
buying the dress from all of those guys
are potential referral partners for you
so meet with them let them know what
you're all about let them know what your
messaging is you know what makes you
different from all the other
photographers and you actually make
their job easier if a bride comes in and
wants a certain kind of style with her
wedding and they know that that matches
up with what you do as a photographer it
will make everybody feel better right
they're providing a service to that
client and they're building a better
relationship by passing their name on to
you as well so those are my three tips
good luck let me know how it goes
and keep believing for those who are
watching you like the video please give
it a thumbs up below let me know what
you think by leaving a comment
underneath or if you have a question put
it below make a video response
if you like the channel you can
subscribe above and see what else I'm
going to come up with soon so thank you
guys and I'll see you soon Cheers